hey youtubers is Charlie welcome to my
personal edition of ask emergency where
I answer a bunch of your guys questions
about me in my channel I've had my
channel for about a year but most of the
videos I make are about specific topics
and not so much about what I'm doing in
my personal life so I just like to do
videos like this to give you guys a
chance to get to know me just a little
bit better just a quick note because
some of the questions that you guys ask
me the same I combined some of my
answers number one Adam Norton asks what
type of camera do you use and what
software do you use to edit your videos
okay so this is basically like a
question about my setup so I use a Canon
60d with a variety of lenses typically
it's a 24 millimeter 270 millimeter lens
my computer is a PC it's a custom build
there's nothing special about it I have
like a gtx 770 and I edit with Creative
Cloud so I use like Premiere Pro and
Photoshop for all those things there are
two different microphones that I use I
do have a live mic that I used to use
that you probably saw on a lot of my
videos but now I've started using my
blue Yeti which you can see right here
have you ever seen a shadow in any of my
videos hanging above my head here it
just means that my mic is just a little
too low super pro I know next question
and number two at a am ski Spyro asks
how much of a fan of anime are you and
which is your favorite I would say my
favorite new anime from this year so far
has been attack on Titan question number
three do you have a full-time job if so
what is it so yes I do have a full-time
job interestingly enough it is also on
YouTube so technically I spend all day
all the time on YouTube I'm just doing
very different things during different
parts of the day so my full-time job is
actually as a YouTube consultant for
companies so I work for a specific
company that has a group of brands like
a bunch of different websites that all
have their own YouTube channels and I
basically just help them be popular on
YouTube all the videos that you see on
this channel that I do are done in my
free time which is why you don't see
more of them all the time question
number four Blair E Blair McGee asks
what's your favorite TV show and movie
right now so ok right now my favorite TV
show is Doctor Who and my favorite big
movie is desolation of smaug and my
favorite small movie is her you know the
Joaquin Phoenix movie typically my
favorite things change pretty frequently
because I watch a lot of stuff question
number five Blanche Mitchell asks do you
read all the comments that get posted
and
you're reading subscribers comments can
usually tell in what age group people
are ok so I do read all the comments I
can't always tell how old people are
because you know a lot of people will
just post comments like that's cool or
awesome the only time it gets really
hard for me to read all the comments is
when a video gets really really popular
like my Doctor Who Easter eggs videos
like those will get thousands and
thousands of comments obviously I can't
read every single one of them but
because of the way new comments works
and it filters top comments so if you
guys are subscribers and you comment a
lot it'll actually put your comments up
at the top so I'll definitely see all
those so the more you comment the more
likely your comments are to be seen
number six cry havoc asks do you talk
this quickly in regular life no I
definitely do not typically I end up
removing a lot of pauses from my youtube
videos like I'll read this and then I'll
put it down and then I'll like I'll just
cut that spaced out so it just seems
like I'm talking faster number seven
Elijah Evans asks what inspired you most
to become a youtuber and what are you
most excited for in 2014 so I've
actually been working on YouTube in a
professional capacity since about 2008
mostly on other people's channels this
is obviously the first channel that's
just been me so I've been around a lot
of creators and I've seen a lot of
different types of content I've seen
comedians I've seen musicians everything
there is on YouTube being around all
these are the people for so long as well
as a lot of my friends becoming big
youtubers really inspired me to take a
chance to just try and have some fun so
I'm really interested to see what kind
of new chances you guys inspire me to
take with the videos that I do next year
number 8 lemon snow asks dude I've seen
your channels steadily pick up
subscribers since the beginning how much
time does it take to put a bit together
where are you trying to take this so
many questions ok so it typically takes
about 4 hours to put a normal video
together sometimes 3 if it's like
something I just watched it really
depends on what kind of video it is so
for instance the Doctor Who Easter eggs
video I did the really big video took a
lot of time that took about 6 hours just
because it takes a lot of research and I
have to go by frame by frame and a lot
of times what I'll do is I'll write
notes down which kind of takes a little
bit of time before I start shooting a
video so I try to do as much preparation
as possible without kind of overdoing it
to answer your other question I really
didn't have a specific end goal in mind
other than to just meet new people
like the things that I liked and wanted
to talk to me about them so for instance
I'm like a Doctor Who video just
typically to find other people to talk
about specific things with so like I
posted a Matt Smith top 11 things video
so that was really just to talk to other
people about their favorite things about
Matt Smith that being said I kind of
take things one week at a time so I
might have a different answer to that
question in six months or even a year
number nine letti Winchester asks what
kind of music are you two so mostly I
listen to EDM on Spotify Spotify private
but I also listen to a lot of guilty
pleasures especially when I've been
working on a video for way too long and
I start to go crazy I'll just listen to
like some stupid 80s music or something
really silly number ten loci LaFace and
asks do you change stuff about the way
you do vids based on what people say and
who are your favorite youtubers to watch
ok so I changed stuff about videos all
the time so if you see my other ask
emergency cue days they look very very
different I try to just change things
just based on what I think is the best
way to do each video that being said I
do try to keep a very specific structure
based on what I find that you guys
really like to watch my favorite
youtubers right now are actually Hank
and John Green on their vlogbrothers
Channel I watched their other channels
too but I like the vlogbrothers stuff
the best my other big favorite is
actually Dodger on her dexterity bonus
channel I really like gaming stuff but I
like her next charity bonus channel like
the personal stuff she does a lot better
too number 11 lone style tribe asks what
is your favorite fandom of all time and
why so I don't have a personal fandom
favorite of all time but right now my
favorite fandom to watch is actually the
Sherlock fandom just because I really
like to geek out on stuff but the fandom
that I also really think is one of the
funniest is probably the supernatural
fandom just because the audience is so
intense like they love Supernatural so
much that that show will probably go to
the end of time they're definitely
they're guaranteed for season 10
basically number 12 movie man reviews
things asks who is the most famous
person you have met okay since I work in
Hollywood I actually run into a lot of
actors all the time so I see famous
people everywhere mostly TV actors not
as many movie actors I would say
recently the most famous person I met is
Joel McHale from community number 13 mr.
Chanin asks if you could own any of the
props from any of the shows you review
what would it
that's an easy one TARDIS hands down
actually Matt Smith's TARDIS I actually
got the touch Matt Smith's TARDIS I
think you got my little TARDIS here I
actually got to touch the real Matt
Smith's TARDIS at the blue box they used
to film during the 50th anniversary
livestream we did at the YouTube space
they literally disassembled the TARDIS
and shipped it to YouTube so that we
could film with it it was amazing number
fourteen Nintendo Lego boy asks how and
when did you decide to make this channel
and did you expect it to get so popular
easy questions when I started this
channel it was totally a goof I don't
know why I picked emergency awesome I
think I just thought it sounded funny
but I really wanted to make a video for
Doctor Who and I just wanted to learn
how to be a better communicator and be
better on camera but I never ever
thought that it would be this big number
15 predator five four three asks
Internet Explorer or Google Chrome so I
would say Google Chrome mostly just
because not only are they supported by
Google a little bit more than the other
browsers but there are a lot of
extensions that Firefox and Safari did
not have number 16 slyfox HD asks how
long have you been on YouTube I would
say since like March of 2008 I started
working on YouTube in a professional
sense on other people's channels there
are still some really old barely
political videos from 2008 like the
barely political channel you know Key of
Awesome there are some videos from 2008
that you could probably find me in the
background of and that's basically how I
learned how to be on YouTube number 17
the FA's Bros asks do you have any tips
for gaining an audience on YouTube so I
actually do this for a living but the
first thing that I will tell you is this
to read the YouTube creators playbook is
an online document and it's super easy
to find but it will give you a good
step-by-step guide about how to kind of
craft your content to build an audience
that being said 1 do not be afraid to
take chances to post videos every day if
you can at least once a day and 3 do not
be afraid to aggressively moderate
comments there will be a lot of trolls
when you first start number 18 the JAXA
people axe asks do you play video games
yes I play a lot of video games not as
much as I'd like to right now most of
the games I play are on Steam I just
bought a ton in the winter sale is going
right now yeah cheap games but I also
have an Xbox one
there are a lot of games for that so
honestly I'm not dedicating a lot of my
time to it most of my time is spent on
my computer so obviously I've been a
computer gamer for most of my life
number 19 the Lord a one asks what film
or TV series are you looking forward to
most that's coming out in the next
couple of years so I'm actually gonna do
a video for this in the next couple of
weeks that'll be much more detailed give
you a much better answer but just to
give you a quick answer one Sherlock
series 3 and community Season 5 make
sure you guys watch both of those shows
they're both going to be amazing and
number 20 William Bryan asks how do you
watch your shows what kind of screen
live or DVR favorite chair the chair
that I sit in 99% of the time is the
chair you guys see right now it's like a
Herman Miller chair I stole it from a
job that I used to have a long long time
ago and it will stay with me till the
day I die is so comfortable but it's so
expensive that I would never have bought
it myself if I didn't you know Bogart it
for free that being said don't steal
stuff seriously don't steal stuff most
of the shows I watched her actually on
my computer monitor here so it's a
budget 27-inch 1440 monitor but most of
my stuff is either streamed or
downloaded just depending on
availability and when it's airing thank
you so much for asking me questions guys
this is actually a lot of fun I'll
probably try and do another personal QA
in like another four or five weeks a lot
of you been asking me about that draw my
life video I'm waiting for about a
hundred thousand subscribers so that
might be like into February early March
so before Game of Thrones comes back
it's kind of what I'm thinking if you
didn't see it on my other video next
week is basically gonna be like a
wholock week it'll be a lot of like
Doctor Who and Sherlock videos in
addition to like my ear and best list
like the best stuff and the best TV
shows from this year and the best movies
I saw be sure to subscribe to get all
that stuff right now click here to get
that Matt Smith the top 11 moments video
and click here to get my Doctor Who Q&A
thank you so much for watching I'll see
you guys tomorrow
high fives
you